traditionally and assimilative culture
we are the oldest continuous
civilization in the world and we have
been evolving ourselves and we have
received stimulus from the flow of
people the flow of ideas into India as
well so culture anywhere is a living
thing but in the Indian case it is much
more assimilative than it has been
perhaps in other areas so is Indian
culture changing and evolving yes is it
changing at a faster pace than it than
in the past yes I think that there is
simultaneously a huge renewal of
interest in our classical art forms
there is a flowering of Indian of
painters modern Indian painters now
command huge prices in international
sales the numbers of writers you know
the literary arena lots and lots of
Indians writing in English making it big
both in the West as well as in India
where there is a large reading public
but also writers in regional languages
in fact you know India today is one of
the few countries where the print media
is absolutely blossoming even as it
loses space elsewhere